hi everyone and welcome to reality check
yes although my biceps are pretty much
there and I can do a mean Scottish
accent I am NOT your regular host
Cameron Robinson who mumbled something
about going away to Barcelona before
scuttling out of the office and handing
me the reigns of the show unfortunately
cam isn't paying me 917 million dollars
for my troubles apparently he just
doesn't have that kind of money right
now but I'll tell you who does online
retailer Amazon and they just paid that
vast sum to acquire the streaming
service twitch which made me wonder why
does twitch work why do we like watching
other people play games
every month 55 million people log on to
twitch to watch other people around the
world play video games
everything from Starcraft to hearthstone
to League of Legends has the potential
to draw in thousands of viewers per
stream but why would anyone in their
right mind choose to watch someone else
play a game instead of who I don't know
choosing to play it themselves well
that's like asking why do people watch
football on the TV luckily some curious
psychologists investigated this and came
up with the motivation scale for sport
consumption identifying key factors that
led to sports spectator consumption
behavior things like the drama of the
match the aesthetics and a feeling of
achievement when your team does well
help draw the viewers in but there are
human factors at play too cultural
anthropologist Johan Huizinga
used the gladiatorial games from Roman
times as a framework for comparison
while only a select group of the
population actually physically took part
the crowd will get a vicarious buzz just
watching much like I get when I watch
people play Ryse son of Rome
just kidding anyway they would feel like
the gladiator was fighting on behalf of
them the spectators researchers Chung
and Wong then identified the 9 personas
no not that kind of persona of those who
spectate online sports I'm not going to
go into all of them but I'll chat a
little bit about those who are most
likely to tune into twitch streams more
regulate let's start with the inspired
the game itself excites them and
watching a stream act as a catalyst for
them to play it themselves so it's
basically like when you follow a game
for a while through preview and review
but you want to check out an extended
stream of it before you take the plunge
and buy it yourself there's also the
pupil those who use streams as their own
personal mr. Miyagi and actually learn
from them take pro League of Legends
players for example they often stream
soloqueue matches publicly during the
day over twitch and talk you through the
tactics that they're using there are
also specific streamers like day9 who
play through games and offer hints and
tips to those watching as there's the
chatbox it's easy for the viewer to
interact with the streamer and ask
question
which is something you don't really get
when you're watching Wimbledon or
another traditional sport the motivation
scale for sport consumption identifies
the drama of the game and the ability
for the spectator to escape from the
real world as things that will appeal to
potential viewers and that's exactly
what draws in our next crowd be
entertained they tune into streams for
the drama the emotion to feel the game
over 32 million people watched the
League of Legends Championship Series
worlds final back in October and huge
events like these away you're likely to
finally entertained
are you not entertained well that go
just go to pentakill so yeah guess I am
and finally let's mash these two groups
together the commentator and the crowd
they tune in for the community aspect
the commentator is more the shoutcaster
who both spectate and performs these
guys run through plays give insight on
players and in doing so shaped the
viewing experience of the other
spectators by providing context within
the commentary then there's the crowd
drawn in by the social aspect of
watching the games these are the
watercooler guys who spectate in a group
and chat about it afterwards well I
guess the twitch equivalent would be the
chat guys who frequent forums
either way it's adding a whole new level
of social interaction and simply just
viewing a game live streaming isn't just
about eSports though plenty of everyday
people like to stream and share their
gaming experiences online but why do we
like to share well it all boils down to
your idea of self image the best version
of you that you can easily control and
unleash upon the world via your social
media and when it comes to video games
an ideal you crops up in more places
than you'd think
like leaderboards what better way to
show the world how amazing we are than
to dominate the top of a scrolling list
of names and numbers but what is it
about leaderboards that make us hammer
the research checkpoint button to get
that high score well we are social
creatures from our time spent monkeying
around in trees to the present day we
like being part of a group leon
festinger's devised the social
comparison theory back
50s suggesting that we have an innate
desire to evaluate ourselves but we're
not exactly sure about how to go about
doing it so we compare ourselves to
those around us in order to assess
ourselves but we are slightly biased
when it comes to who we compare
ourselves to if we compare our gaming
chops to someone whose skill levels
vastly outweigh ours then our
self-esteem is going to take a hit which
is why leaderboards are more effective
when you're up against people who are
similar to you like your friends which
is why things like friends only
leaderboards the ghostrider from trials
and despite the Daffy name drive Attar's
works so well if our friends can do it
then we believe that we can do it
because we think we have the same skill
set because we're similar in other
regards so that's why we strive for
supremacy on online leaderboards but why
do we post about games on our social
networks well take a look at the
popularity of Facebook games like
Farmville and mafia wars while the
addictive gameplay of these titles has
been investigated new research suggests
that there's more at work when it comes
to explaining why people play yes those
will you give me an extra life and will
you water my crops notifications are
annoying for those of us who don't
partake so why do people post them in
the first place in-game rewards aside
researchers of the Michigan State
University conducted a study which
suggests that people use these social
network games not to intentionally make
new social connections but rather to
maintain and enhance the ones they
already have using the game as the soil
for the conversation it allows a safe
warm and damp base for the relationship
to flourish so the recipients can
harvest some sweet friend fruit wait
I've got way too deep into the farmville
scenario but you get what I mean
so that's all for this week why do you
feel the need to share let me know in
the comments below we're on something of
a twitch kick at the moment while we
were at Gamescom a couple of weeks ago
cam called into the LCS to ask some pro
League of Legends players if playing
live in front of thousands or streaming
live in front of millions affected their
gameplay tune in next week to watch a
ron's come trying to answer that
question you can catch me on Twitter at
Lucy James games thanks for watching
science friends we'll see you next time
you